[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag
la mobilité est une problématique
récurrente des territoires plus défié
les déplacements des populations limiter
les transports individuels au profit des
transports collectifs dans le respect de
l'environnement
les défis pris à bras le corps par les
communautés de saint quentin en yvelines
vous explique tout dans ce numéro c'est
parti
[Musique]
et
à saint quentin en yvelines territoire
de 230 mille habitants les possibilités
de déplacement sont multiples et à
chacun sa préférence le bus j'ai pris le
train tu crois l'ebit mon véhicule je
prends ma voiture et je travaille à
proximité de mon domicile c'est à dire à
plaisir je prends le train tous les
jours pour travailler à paris et je
prends le bus pour mes déplacements ici
en fait un plaisir
j'utilise ma voiture c'est plus facile
pour moi d'aller au travail en voiture
essentiellement le vélo pour aller à la
gare et après je prends le train pour
jean taille c'est le vélo mon domicile
juste à côté de mon travail 3 km en 2014
saint quentin en yvelines était la
première collectivités franciliennes a
approuvé son plan local de déplacement
un plan révisé suite à l'adoption du
nouveau plan de déplacements urbains de
la région et de france
ce nouveau programme vise notamment à
favoriser les alternatives aux véhicules
individuels
les enjeux sont nombreux il ya déjà des
enjeux
développement économique saint quentin
ville est un territoire extrêmement
attractif pour les entreprises deuxième
pib dit de france et si nous voulons
garder
l'entreprise de décès de la recherche
des universités des centres de formation
etc
donc nous avons logement
effectivement de différent
le transport d'autant plus que beaucoup
de
personnes qui travaillent dans ces
entreprises n'habitent pas forcément
d'un mètre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
tous que j'utilise
leur voiture d'un véhicule personnel sur
des axes qui sont pour beaucoup d'entre
eux très saturé un territoire disparates
entre villes nouvelles et villes
anciennes dans lesquelles se mêlent
grands boulevards et rues étroites et
pour fluidifier ces axes l'heure est aux
alternatives et dans ces alternatives
il y a le réseau de bus qui fait
actuellement l'objet d'une vaste
restructuration
l'objectif est de renforcer les lignes
fortes afin de gagner en attractivité
sur l'ensemble du territoire
95 lignes desservent
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 59 dont 26
courses scolaires relève de la
compétence directe du territoire autour
de ski bus cinq opérateurs locaux
hourtoule stave au perrier mobilité et
savak ses 59 lits effectué 20 millions
de voyages par an le territoire est
maillé avec les pôles urbains
environnants par dix lignes express
--une mille nocturne
et pour restructurer au mieux le réseau
saint quentin en yvelines a consulté sa
population en septembre 2016 afin de
connaître les besoins de chacun des
besoins importants puisque près de 3000
saint quentinois ou répondu à cette
enquête
l'agglomération a est reconnue autorités
organisatrices de proximité pour porter
les projets de développement de l'offre
de bus auprès de mobilité ile de france
anciennement stif depuis 2011
elle a donc réuni les maires des douze
communes pour ce projet mais aussi ses
partenaires mobilité ile-de-france et
les entreprises le redéploiement du
réseau de bus sera effectif dès la fin
de l'année 2018 pour les communes les
moins desservis les clayes-sous-bois
plaisir villepreux mais aussi maurepas
coignières et magny les hameaux
un redéploiement qui se poursuivra
jusqu'en 2024
avec l'arrivée de la ligne 18
l'objectif de cette restructuration
c'est d'avoir davantage de l'us d'un
week-end et en soirée c'est également
une meilleure attractivité avec des
lignes plus forte et plus fréquentes et
une meilleure desserte et une meilleure
information aussi avec le entre autres
le système
salmon river systems dead à
l'exploitation et à l'information aux
voyageurs
il
à terme 72% de la population et 49 % des
emplois du territoire seront à moins de
400 mètres d'une ligne forte contre
respectivement 49 et 23 % aujourd'hui la
mobilité c'est aussi le ferroviaire les
gars sont au nombre de sept sur le
territoire saint quentin en yvelines
souhaite moderniser ses pôles de
déplacement afin qu'ils deviennent de
véritables lieux d'échangés multimodaux
après avoir restructuré le pôle gare de
saint quentin en yvelines
l'agglomération ont repensé la gare de
la verrière un projet d'envergure avec
la construction d'un parc relais pour le
stationnement des véhicules
la reconfiguration de la gare routière
la réalisation de stations vélos et deux
roues motorisés de pistes cyclables de
dépose reprise minutes et d'une station
taxi sans oublier une insertion
paysagère des espaces publics
le pôle gare est conçu en corrélation
avec le projet de carrefour de la malle
me donne la future zac des bécanes et le
doublement du pont guy schuller
si que la réalisation du transport en
commun en site propre entre les gares de
la verrière et de trappes
la ligne 18 nous l'avons évoqué tout à
l'heure elle représente la future ligne
du métro grand paris express prévue à
l'horizon 2030
le planning pourrait s'accélérer grâce à
l'obtention cet été des jo-2000 24 par
paris la suite est prévue en 2030 dont
les délais sera raccourcie donc un 2024
qui est extrêmement effectivement
important pour nous ça quentin en
yvelines important pour sonder la fois
économique à pouvoir aussi avoir ses
réalisations qui permettra justement de
mettre notre comment dire autres modes
de déplacements et d'éviter de prendre
les deux premiers matches en outre
maquis sont plus en plus encombré autre
projet sur la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines la vélostation situé sur la
place charles de gaulle et sur l'avenue
paul delouvrier elle ouvrira ses portes
à l'automne
deux cent trente vélos pour inciter les
usagers à délaisser leur voiture un
service accessible avec une carte navigo
et un abonnement annuel compris entre 10
et 30 euros
autre service de cette vélostation la
location de 170 bicyclette vélo
classique électrique ou pliable la
vélostation proposera également un
atelier de réparation et d'entretien
un investissement de 600 mille euros
répartis entre la région le stif et
l'agglomération
vous l'aurez compris le territoire saint
quentinois encourage largement
l'utilisation des circulations douces
l'agglomération complot 235 km de pistes
cyclables un circuit qui va poursuivre
son développement et pour cette rentrée
l'agglomérât
edit le premier plan des pistes
cyclables des douze communes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vélo les transports d'aujourd'hui sont
redéployés sur le territoire mais quid
de la mobilité de demain
réponse avec nos experts l'estaca
acteurs du territoire qui forment les
ingénieurs de demain est fait germer les
mobilités du futur a plus d'une corde à
son arc nous faire bouger autrement les
2000 ingénieurs de l'école travaille de
concert avec les entreprises du
territoire et les partenaires
institutionnels signé un bail et
christophe delisle nous ont éclairés sur
ce qui nous attend dans un avenir proche
aujourd'hui on forme des ingénieurs sont
quatre domaines l'automobile les
transports guidés spatiale et puis
l'aéronautique aujourd'hui les
problématiques qui sont posées c'est
patent et prometic technique c'est
surtout des problématiques du haj aussi
des problématiques de sécurité des
promoted comportements humains des
problématiques de
d'écologie il ya une révolution
automobile inquiet en cours sur le
véhicule autonome sur le véhicule de
partage et puis sur le besoin des
personnes qui utilisent l'automobile qui
est complètement différent il ya dix ans
aujourd'hui les gens veulent pas
forcément avoir un véhicule et encore
moins le conduire et la plupart sont
plutôt ouverts sur le véhicule
électrique donc ça se développe beaucoup
les infrastructures autour aussi pour
recharger par exemple ces véhicules sur
des routes spécifiques et donc on a
quelques projets notamment quelques
exemples avec le territoire comme il
sera suspendu bien évidemment pas de
véhicule autonome aussi aujourd'hui on
en a pas sur des routes ouvertes mais on
en a qui roule sur des circuits privés
on en a qui roule pas la défonce on a
une navette qui autonome et qui fait qui
va d'un point a à un point b mais
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que dans un
véhicule
il est presque autonome et véhicules qui
sortent aujourd'hui avec les hadas que
là bas la conduite vous avez lentilles
collision lane assist il est plein de
choses qui font que le véhicule est
autonome pendant un certains nombre de
minutes et je pense que d'ici deux trois
ans on aura vraiment une visibilité sur
le véhicule autonome donc les véhicules
seront connectés et comme ils seront
connectés ils seront par avance où sont
les embouteillages puisque les veilles
le véhicule sera un embouteillage signe
à la rareté de véhicules qui est un
embouteillage pour prendre un autre
itinéraire est fini les embouteillages
l'agglomération étudie également de
nouvelles solutions de mobilité pour les
déplacements du quotidien comme les
navettes suspendu développé par la start
up supra wise
on transporte de demain on a ce type de
navettes c'est-à-dire d'extrader
véhicules en suspension ça serait plutôt
mon avis la mode de transport destinés à
des voix réadapter style voilà si vous
arrivez départementale pour info les
personnes et qui seraient des navettes
sur des
très légère marsan en partie à l'énergie
solaire qui sont un petit peu comme des
sortes de ménibus suspendu huit à dix
personnes soit environ et qui serait
donc électrique et ne pas oublier le
plan de déplacement inter entreprises il
sera étendu aux villans 30 dans le
courant de l'année 2018
l'agglomération en collaboration avec
mobilité ile de france mettra aussi en
place dès 2018
un calculateur d'itinéraire en temps
réel à l'échelle du territoire
à pied à vélo en voiture ou en
transports l'internaute pourra trouver
en un clic le chemin le plus rapide pour
arriver à bon port
vous savez tous désormais sur la
mobilité à saint quentin en yvelines
à vous de choisir votre mode de
déplacement
[Musique]